hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to three scary games
this one's called death trips it markets
itself as an extremely short horror game
inspector M James lead inspector M James
is in a hunt for a serial killer called
lady death the last victim of this
dreadful criminal was found in this
cheap hotel where lady James is
currently investigating unfortunately
for the inspector the murderer is still
there
oh well that's wait no wait hang on I'm
wait hang on now listen I'm the
inspector and the murderer is still
there you say well well how lovely
oh all right up the elevator we go then
I don't gotta do nothing that I don't
even need to push a button on the fourth
floor
it'll take me where I want to go I just
imagine what floor I want then it goes
there I didn't want to go here ah much
better but some way
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
all right do blink unlike games where
you don't blink you have to do blink you
have to do the blink you have to be
blinking the do you have to do the
blinking thing with your eyes you have
to slap your lids together as hard as
you can so that you do in fact blink you
gotta do the blink hey I haven't started
the game yet okay you live in a shelter
inside a dangerous and cold forest the
door is shut and you lost your key Hey
you're trapped outside now try to find
your keen go back to your shelter before
something else finds you it seems that
they can't see you if you close your
eyes well that's weird it's like a it's
like a nine year olds defense to the
boogeyman and it's closet
okay blink to start the game oh god this
game got me already wait nope
now it got me okay how do I blink ah I
got a scroll with my mouse I'm going to
turn my mouse into turbo mode I got a
button here that makes my mass wheel
just go boom
exactly like that well alright we in
baby what do we got I gotta find my key
it is loud in this cold dreary forest
alright hey is anybody in there
oh no okay so um this Baldy out in these
woods
you're gonna slap my ass around oh okay
that's probably nothing it's probably
just some very very hungry thunder or
something like that right there's a
storm rolling in you know how it is with
these winter storms
I can't sprint at all I just like
lackadaisical ooh I lackadaisically go
through the woods find some firewood or
something or masturbate behind a tree I
don't know what's the squeaky door hey
hey hey listen you don't need to watch
me
I'm just doing my bit whoa hey tree hey
tree Hey
Wow all right Oh gone all right then
weird okay do I gotta find like the
seven pieces of my key I wouldn't be
surprised if that was kind of the idea
here gotta build my own key kit out in
the woods get some soap dirt spit that I
say something that should be concerned
about or is that nothing cuz it sounds
like a whole lot of something right
though okay you're a you're either
hungry here you're just [ __ ] with me
and I'm gonna assume that you're just
[ __ ] with me cuz I don't see anything
over there I see nothing and I don't
know if I gotta be lookin out for a tiny
speck of a key why why would you do that
don't do that don't do that come on now
you're being ridiculous you're being
ridiculous
don't be ridiculous come on now also I
got a sneaking suspicion that I'm
probably walking out here butt naked
look I stepped out for a after a shower
cuz I saw him doorbell dingdong ditched
me and I stepped out in a towel
I'm just blood ass naked out here and I
can well alright did that help
who was this it's the first
distinguishable landowner
oh well whoa I'm on this rock you can
where I can't see you
oh I'm gonna back away slowly I'm a
peekaboo a little bit peek-a-boo
peek-a-boo eat gobble peekaboo oh oh oh
this game took a turn okay all right
okay all right you're naked I'm naked I
don't want to see you naked you
definitely don't want to see me naked so
we got to play a game of peekaboo in the
forest over here yeah how am I gonna see
how am I gonna know if I found the key
or not I know I'm going back towards it
but just because I want to see if
there's anything about this rock
formation or something like that I don't
know yeah all right now that I know
there's a credible threat in this forest
now I'm a little more worried i mean i
sneaky suspicion that something uh i had
a sneaking suspicion to something
dangerous was in these woods but i'm i'm
generally understanding that it's not
too bad of a problem should i just
wander out into the j-just go into the
Siberian wilderness dig myself my own
grave and then jump in face-first
I feel like cannonball into my hungry Oh
huh okay why'd you do that who's trying
to see what's up whoa yeah that's big
you're bigger than I thought you was
whoa I didn't know if he were actually
here thing and by I didn't know you were
actually think I didn't know you were
wandering out in the middle of
everywhere
no peekaboo I can't see you you can't
see me good boy that was a mistake
I gotta stop that that's bad that's one
of those Bad's I'm doing it again doing
it a little bigger book okay it's behind
that tree I don't think it's a me but I
have no idea where I'm going
huh okay I don't like I'm just gonna
squid I'm gonna be real species realist
especia what's going on here keeps it
quiet I can actually hear myself think I
have no idea where the queue would be I
went on the outskirts I might try to
make another big circle but I'm gonna go
in Roseau you're not here are you
yeah you're not here big stupid piece of
poop you smelly - you're ugly Wow I tend
to call him ugly that really did it whoa
I think I saw an ass look like an ass
don't look back I'm not looking back
what do you mean don't look back don't
look back
I'm looking back don't tell me what to
do you can't tell me how to live my life
you can't tell me how to live my life I
don't know what I was doing but oh [ __ ]
there you are I see you what are you
gonna do about it
Oh glee your piece of poopie huh you a
piece of poopie the answer is yes
the answer is very much yes I don't know
maybe that's whoa hey oh that's that's
helpful that's that's helpful that's
very obvious okay I got the key I get my
naked ass back in my own house this is
right here the whole time I could have
seen that if that [ __ ] hadn't come
charging at me down out of the blue so
I'm just gonna be enter my way assume
that nothing's gonna go up nothing's
gonna come get me on my way back to my
own house my own house is my own house
it's my house it's mine the house is
mine
you're a little scary you're scary I
don't like you I don't like this idea of
closing my eyes I like seeing I like
knowing where I'm going okay the guy I
think I'm in the clear I think I'm in
the clear
either give me the clue I'm not in the
clear oh I'm in the clear I'm in the
clear
I'm in the clear yeah I'm in the clear
I'm fine I'm fine I'm fine I'm fine I am
fine fine is what I am I'm sure I'll be
safe in this flimsy wooden building that
thing definitely couldn't knock down the
walls it won't have it won't puff it
definitely won't blow me down open that
door
yeah I'm safe for now send a noose oh
boy okay
oh that's it okay goody goody gumdrops
that was great that was good that was
good I like that I like that that was
good that was good I like that I like
that okay but we're not done all right
so this one's called woven shadows I'm
guessing it is something to do with
spiders so if this tickles your fancy
you about to get spidered oh look at
that happy family I'm not I'm not right
about this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay thanks Richard thanks dick thank
you dick okay death to all phones why
would why would Richard take the boot
drive out of the computer in the first
place that doesn't make any sense what
is this
what is this let's say shite
alright boot drive is is a boot dress
okay are Renea nice whoa oh haha
santé yeah it's a little empty what is
this a five nights at Freddy's thing Jim
whoa
Jim's looking a little messed up man Jim
is looking messed up okay cafe next
janitorial what am I looking at these
for whoa what is that
math Oh Oh gross
it was spider gross okay so then what
wha Jim whoa that's a big spider oh boy
that's a good sign okay spider can knock
out my equipment as yeah check the
tablet that's better definitely better
than a computer can eject its critter
ejected oh okay
show me the cameras what's the magic
word okay press tab to open a RNA
assistance on your tablet oh that's
handy kitchen camera cafe what what
happened hello oh boy let's not do that
that's something that we could not do oh
[Music]
oh oh D horn Rams okay that's not good
that's what one might call not good okay
whoo ha hee ha oh I guess we're just
into it where do we don't we don't even
have any commentary about that we don't
even have anything to say about things
going wonky like that we just got to go
for it yeah ok so what am i what am I
trying to accomplish here what am I
trying to do am i trying to get the
power back on is it whoo use your map
get to the cafe use your map if you need
it okay so cafe where did I just come
from what am i where am i okay so these
are the classrooms this is a long
hallway
that's a wraparound so the only
wraparound is here office long hall wait
go down this way Cafe is on the other
side of this hallway I'm on the wrong
side okay
I've got good orientation skills it's
been awhile since I've been in school
but I know my way around at school
so this should lead right to the cafe
right no yes
this is perfect I love it oh I'm dead
no god damn it every goddamn time I'm
just getting into something and then you
do that [ __ ] to me to me yeah all right
so that I'm not gonna leave it there
let's listen another one oh ah this
looks neat Oh started up I don't know
what life is all about but it says short
[Music]
[Music]
hmm interesting so someone was a dick
and then someone's left oh yeah really
working hard sleeping on that couch are
you Oh problem problem problem bro what
oh hi okay hello are you the guy from
welcome to the game to the guy I hate
very very much
are you that guy as I don't like you oh
look at the water oh oh it's lovely miss
studio presents wow wow this is alright
okay you got a little bit of production
quality going on here all right you flex
it but it's alright okay I get it
you got flex you got a do you got
show-off I get it looks good looks good
I'm into it I'm ready
show me something good I'm ready
Oh am i upside down is this this guy's
ass nice ass buddy so you've been doing
your squats some deadlifts here and
there me I've been doing nothing hey man
that's why you're carrying me and I'm
not carrying myself on my red LIFO
that's on the floor but I like it good
style huh
uh-huh yes why I am a wank be rude be
less rude why don't you
oh is that my blood
oh so now I'm gonna be ass just gonna
watch it mama you noticed this song
better so you should be able to tell
it's a little you
you're not the same you're not gonna be
a dick you're gonna pretty much gonna do
and free anything to get your ass out of
there [ __ ] no not really I'm good buddy
if you were more polite maybe I'd be
more interested but I I'm obstinate
a man whose voice is Wow
who's Peter four and two and three
sir beautiful f it is not that rules in
earth of scale see where the best this
thing doctor is straight
forgive the comic relief now I'm to be
generous and I'm gonna help
big giveaway were looking for I didn't
even hear the riddle
sure beautiful a friend is not but boobs
in earth of Skiles see women bears to
beat this thing what what I don't well I
don't even what when it's thing to
repeat it repeat the riddle repeat it
I'm pressing or I don't know what's my
ass the five letters my ass you sure
it's not my ass oh I can't even type it
it weren't Roger
Rogers got three legs care carat with
one space dog oh oh there I now see the
saw okay I see it now okay I see the
song I see this on now umm stool chair
chair I don't want to [ __ ] you but you
know you're offering ouchie ouchie
Moochie oh yeah we're gonna skip this
skip I didn't even know that was a sigh
but those like a drawer or something oh
come on now
I'm trying to get this try to get it man
I'm trying so mutable voice of one can
what has feet but doesn't really go okay
what has feet a guy as feet uh
caterpillar has feet ah has legs I guess
it doesn't have feet the only thing with
feet are like chairs and stools and like
I don't know like look peaches maybe
they have feet oh maybe like a dog they
have Tootsie's all right I had to look
this up cuz it don't make no sense it
don't make no sense it's human but
all right cool thanks that was great
human that didn't make any sense that
made no sense that made no sense maybe
I'm just dumb but that didn't make what
happens if I walk into this ow
oh you cha all right there we go
well I'm dead all right all right so now
we're gonna actually try this for
realsies uh how we're gonna hey nice
heads are those real heads are those
just mannequins I'm gonna assume those
are mannequins because I doubt that real
heads would be well maybe they're real
it might be real one of these buckets of
you got like flex glue in there you like
flex you ever seen that they cut a boat
in half pretty cool huh
all right what do we got here whoa oh oh
on four feet your dust go slow
oh you dust go slow on four to sees
their hands they're not feet they're not
feet oh hi
don't like you none thanks for putting
bras on them and underwear appreciate
that that's that helpful for my me
getting banned on you too okay but what
about this one what about all righty
then
okay well that was a pleasant one I'm
glad I listened to that let's go in the
sunflower room that sounds so nice it's
actual sunflowers
more spiders okay
well oh all right I hate this place I
hate this whoa oh you make less noise
when growling of course I do
everybody knows no no no no no no no no
no no no I don't know where I'm going
I'll bet this key in here that I need to
find in Izzy is with me did I just spin
around in a soy cool I think I did I did
[Music]
okay it's probably fine these spiders
aren't too much of a problem I think so
long as I don't run into him I think I
should be okay right
that makes sense that probably makes
sense everybody knows that make sense
that makes sense I always make sense
since it's the only thing that I know
how to make I don't know where I'm going
I don't know what I'm looking for I hope
it's bright and glowy like that other
key that I saw in that other game are
you doing oh no no no no no no no no no
no no no no
ah all right so it's somewhere in here
it's just I don't know where I don't
know where it is but it's somewhere oh
oh there's a door
oh well that's easier can I have it can
I have that thank you
I can have that and I can get out of
here right then I can just leave and
then I'm done right and then I'm done
then I'm out of here baby
then I'm out scot-free ain't no spider
gonna crawl up my butt ain't no spider
gonna mess up my day I'm gonna be 100%
fine and done easy-peasy lemon squeeze
me riddles keys all good all done okay
can I go now all right like I run with a
backwards lean-to my flashlight waving
around in the air well then it's not
really a choice is it it's just it's
just a 50/50 shot that's not really a
choice at least they're not pleading
with me who'd you see if you kind of
subservient okay I'll just for Dinka
Dinka well that was um that was a thing
all right no okay I'll do
hello life oh is that you who's slapping
in the darkness you fapping you fapping
not be fine okay well alright oh my ice
grabby hands Oh
ah alright so not bad the production
quality was okay uh it's like some of
the choices that they made in the game
itself were a little odd like it wasn't
actually like good gameplay there oh
what's this oh it's just starting over
again it wasn't like it wasn't like the
gameplay itself is good the puzzles
weren't engaging and fun to solve the
spider bit was kind of cool but at the
same time it also was a little
frustrating cuz it was less like less
like my actions and more of this random
passing of a spider and just always
crouched instead of being like
subjectively crouched crap sometimes and
in certain circumstances it didn't feel
like I was impactful of anything and
then the riddle was just too weird and
hard in the first place but either way
thank you everybody so much for watching
this has been three scary games with a
little extra if you want to see more
scary games that I've done I've got a
huge playlist down there and many other
scary games that I've played that aren't
even in that playlist they're in
playlists of their own go check them out
on the playlist tab on my channels home
page
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
[Music]